[Música]
olá meu nome é maria do lado e eu tenho
10 anos quando soube que eu vim aqui
participar do pedex que escolheu uma
coisa que tivesse tudo a ver com
tecnologia entretenimento e design e
mídia digital tem tudo isso
a mídia digital é uma nova forma de se
comunicar através das novas tecnologias
com a mídia digital a comunicação ficou
muito mais rápida
a questão alguns exemplos de mídias
digitais
só quando você vai no shopping e você vê
aquelas telas gueant está sendo
propaganda de algum produto e são
painéis ea quem são um exemplo mas
também existem outras como o whatsapp
facebook instagram 30 ea tv corporativa
que normalmente utilizado em grandes
empresas porque as empresas usam as
mídias digitais
as empresas duas mídias digitais para
fazer propaganda de seu produto e para
se comunicar entre si os benefícios das
mídias digitais como eu já tinha falado
antes é que a comunicação ficou muito
mais rápida e sustentável mas porque
sustentável
vocês sabiam que parece comune pt press
produzir uma folha de papel é necessário
gastar 1 litro d'água e derrubar uma
árvore mas tudo em excesso faz mal usa
geradas digitais podem trazer doenças
como obesidade e sonha
além de afetar também as relações
interpessoais e as relações entre pais e
filhos
aqui estão algumas recomendações que
foram publicadas em 2016 no ano passado
sobre as mídias digitais até dois anos
não é recomendável de 2006
metais pois quem essa velocidade não
consegue imaginar o que vem na tela com
a vida real a partir de dois anos a que
as crianças podem se beneficiar muito os
vegetais é isso inclusive até mostram
melhores cognitivas e linguísticas em
quem elas que tem que ter um tempo
limitado
agora vou mostrar um vídeo pra vocês de
como fazer a mídia digital
[Música]
vejam algumas características de pessoal
é a hora livre e vocês vão perceber que
elas estão sorrindo porque elas se
divertem tem como se divertir ao ar
livre sabia que vocês verão pessoas
andando de bicicleta correndo na grama
em que muitos outros
agora eu vou lançar um desafio todas as
crianças que também no ac em todo mundo
fiquem só três horas nas mídias digitais
no máximo e no resto do dia vocês me
perguntam o que pode fazer vocês podem
descobrir coisas como ler livros fazer
colagens entre muitos outros
e vocês verão que vocês vão estar com
saúde vão estar usando a mídia digital
com inteligência e também vão se
divertir e ser mais inteligente porque
vocês não está descobrindo muito mais
coisas
eu já fiz a minha parte fico só duas
horas nas regiões genitais e vocês vão
fazer a sua muito obrigada
[Aplausos]